Russian missile strikes knocked out four
electrical substations in leviv two are
completely destroyed leaving people once
again in the dark this time about 30
percent of the city is without power and
that's having a ripple effect on water
supplies and cell service
on the other side of the country more
signs of Destruction and death at least
five were killed Tuesday in a series of
Rocket attacks in zaparizia officials
say the school medical facility and a
car dealership were hit
it was loud things were flying over here
I rushed to the hallway children were
crying
ukrainians have endured 230 days of
shelling and tears
Russia must be completely isolated and
punish Vladimir zielinski told G7
leaders in a virtual meeting the
Ukrainian president's number one ask was
for Effective and modern air defense
systems G7 leaders pledged military
financial and humanitarian support for
as long as it takes Canada's minister of
National Defense offered up More Than
Just Words of support Canada will deploy
approximately 40 combat engineers to
Poland to help polish forces train
Ukrainian soppers on engineer
reconnaissance explosives Mining and
demining Monday's attacks are the
largest series of strikes away from the
front lines since the start of the
invasion in February the costs to Russia
in people and Equipment a staggering and
we know and Russian military commanders
know that their supplies and munition
are running out the UK's spy Chief says
Putin has misjudged the situation and
suffered multiple strategic failures
from Russia nothing but a show of force
new defense videos show off cruise
missile launches and on-site training
inspections of recently mobilized troops
Ukraine has reclaimed large swaths of
territory in recent weeks but people are
back to spending hours underground
knowing their safety is not guaranteed
anywhere in the country
Crystal commencing Global News London